les pistards de l'équipe de france était
sous les feux des projecteurs ce jeudi 4
octobre
la fédération a dévoilé officiellement
les noms des sportifs qui participeront
à l'étape de coupe du monde organisée du
19 au 21 octobre au vélotour national de
saint quentin en yvelines dont vous
pouvez voir dans l'équipe de france il
ya des coureurs expérimentés qui ont
déjà participé à plusieurs jeux
olympiques plusieurs champions du monde
et puis des jeunes donc ça c'est
également vrai en endurance notamment
chez les filles donc on doit et de
scorer dans toutes les disciplines ski
ce qui est possible dans les anciens
l'autre alors au tour de grégory baugé
neuf fois champion du monde et la
présence de ligne montrent un françois
pervis cette fois couronné au niveau
mondial ce dernier nourrit de grandes
ambitions sur cette compétition à 33 ans
il faut pas se louper puisque dans deux
ans il va falloir avoir assez de points
pour avoir tous les quotas au niveau de
déchets olympique donc c'est très
important
la nouvelle génération sera quant à elle
symbolisé par deux visages sébastien
vigier 21 ans et mathilde de gros 19 ans
cette dernière va endosser le rôle de
favorite sur cette compétition à
domicile après un titre européen cet été
c'est énorme pour moi ça va être la
première fois que je vis une grosse
compétition ici à domicile donc voilà va
falloir essayer de ne pas trop se mettre
la pression ça va être une chose
nouvelle pour moi on va voir comment je
réagis j'espère que ça se passera bien
et j'espère que je donne enfin que tout
cas j'aurai une belle médaille pour mes
amis et ma famille cette équipe de
france devrait se produire devant plus
de dix mille spectateurs sur ces trois
jours de compétition vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]